hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in on the ends Cicero has torquatus
represent the epicurean position in
ethics and Epicureans our hedonist they
hold that pleasure is not just a good
but the good it is the highest good the
Summum bonum and it is the final end the
thing that should be motivating us and
indeed does motivate us according to
them whether we realize it or not and
everything else is to be understood in
light of pleasure or in light of pain
its opposite which is the final evil the
worst evil the end of bad things
everything else is bad in relation to
pain or the loss or lack of pleasures
now torquatus is in an interesting
position here and his interlocutor
points this out as opposed to say
Epicurus himself who was you know a
philosopher living in a garden that he
selected for himself with with some
friends who he had to enjoy a common
life and enjoy philosophy with over the
course of his life Turk wadis is coming
from a noble family he's coming from a
family that has done important deeds in
the history of Rome prior to this this
dialogue so this raises the problem his
interlocutor says you know think about
your great ancestors they didn't just
evaluate things in terms of their
pleasure and pain or else they wouldn't
have done the great things that they did
they wouldn't have engaged in noble
deeds and so the question here is since
he has ancestors who have displayed not
just a little bit of virtue but great
moral virtue is why did they engage in
this virtuous action now why are we
talking about virtue here virtue for the
other philosophies that were out there
provided an example of something that
you could say this does
reduced to pleasure and vice it's office
that doesn't just reduce to pain to
engage in virtuous activity is not
always pleasant for oneself as a matter
of fact it may be quite unpleasant
sacrificing your life for your country
isn't that something that would be
painful fighting against the enemy
itself I mean you might didn't really
enjoy fighting for a little while but I
think a lot of fighting back then was
not quite so fun
maybe virtue is about something
different and Turk wata says no no no I
can explain all of this so the question
is why did these ancestors do the things
they did why did they engage in these
virtuous noble you know deeds that would
would attain them and a moral reputation
then we can even talk about today so he
tells us that here we go I'm not gonna
be bribed by your flattery of my family
what's the explanation you put on their
actions why did they charge an armed
enemy why did they treat their children
cruelly without a thought for their own
interest in advantage what even while
the animals don't act that way so what
was the motive he says if they had a
motive for these glorious exploits it
was not a love of virtue in and for
itself virtue is not something desirable
in and for itself from an epicurean
position or standpoint what was it that
they were doing then why were they
engaging in these deeds that would earn
them glory and earn some sort of
advantage to Rome he says consider my
ancestor who rested the neck let this is
why torquatus right from his his foe the
tork he saved himself from death but he
braved great
danger yes before the eyes of an army so
he wouldn't have just done this in a bar
fight or done this you know willy-nilly
some other place he did it in specific
circumstances why in front of the army
what was he trying to win
he says honor and esteem and why does he
want those here's where we get to a
distinctively epicurean position
torquatus says well honor and esteem are
the strongest security that you can have
in life so he was really doing something
dangerous to produce a state of greater
security for himself what about others
one of them sentenced his own son to
death and he says well he better have
had some good reason for doing that
because if he didn't that I'm sorry to
be the descendant of somebody who's so
savage but if his purpose was by
inflicting some pain upon himself to
establish his authority as a commander
and to tighten the reins of discipline
then his action aimed at ensuring the
safety of his own fellow citizens upon
which he knew his own dependents so
again a matter of security a matter of
some sort of greater good being brought
about a matter of ruling out certain
pains and guaranteeing certain pleasures
by engaging in those actions now the way
that torquatus is going to talk about
this in general could apply to the rest
of us when we engage in virtuous actions
what we're doing is one of two things
perhaps both at the same time we are
foregoing pleasures in the present for
greater pleasures in the future or we
are enduring pains in the presence so
that we can avoid greater pains in the
future so if for example we're being
generous to somebody who we see in
poverty
perhaps we
that will get some sort of greater
reward for that or perhaps what it is
that we really want is to be looked at
as somebody who gets to be generous and
that we that we value more than the
money or resources that we provide them
with and we can go on and on and on with
other sorts of examples of this
so torquatus says the famous examples of
my relatives don't really prove that
virtue is something good in and of
itself something that has intrinsic
moral value the moral value that virtue
really does have and he thinks that it
does have moral value derives from how
it helps us to produce or to safeguard
pleasures and to prevent or to avoid
pains we take a little bit of pain or
even a great amount of pain to avoid
much greater pain later on or indeed to
attain pleasures for ourselves we forego
certain pleasures to avoid greater pains
or to attain greater pleasures for our
self in the future or perhaps even in
the present so he goes on and he tells
us that all of the pleasures tend to
produce Verte all the virtues tend to
produce pleasures in one way he also
goes on he says I understand there's a
lot of people out there who are mistaken
about the moral status of virtue they
think that virtue is the good the Stoics
would be a prime example of this but
Aristotelian also in a certain way and
plaintiffs would be making that the good
as well
so if that's really the case then
pleasure and pain would be rather
incidental but for the Epicureans it's
the opposite of that he says those who
put the chief good in pleasure the
Summum bonum the best
good are being fooled they're captive
they are they're being seduced by a name
by a verbal expression this virtue
business anything else that we want to
call it being upright being a good
person more importantly he says they
fail to understand what it is that
nature requires of them and so there is
an intimation here this is that to
pursue virtue solely for its own sake
might be to misunderstand human nature
and to get the virtues wrong to not
really engage in the virtues but only
something that would be let's call it a
facsimile of it virtues ought to be
productive of pleasure and to ward off
pains and he will discuss the four
cardinal virtues each of them in
particular and those are wisdom justice
temperance and courage and try to
provide some arguments on an epicurean
basis for why each of them is going to
produce greater pleasure than pain for
the person who develops and who deploys
that virtue so for the Epicureans
according to torquatus virtue can be
seen as a good but it's merely a means
to the greater good of pleasure
you